[Musik]
zusammen hier ist wieder hätte erfreute
live eurer live stream zu aktuellen
ereignissen und die welt schaut heute
nach washington dc denn joe biden wird
in wenigen minuten als der 46 präsident
der vereinigten staaten vereidigt
donald trump ist damit erstmal
geschichte der hat sich heute schon
verabschiedet das gucken wir uns nachher
nochmal alles an während wir darauf
warten dass es in washington losgeht
wir werden nachher sprechen mit meiner
kollegen an dieser jung und mit kathrin
klug politikwissenschaftlerin an der
harvard kennedy school die sich auch
natürlich gut auskennt die uns ein paar
fragen beantworten wird was das ganze
jetzt so besonders macht aber erstmal
möchte ich zu meiner kollegin an dieser
jungs schalteten die in washington in
der nähe des kapitols steht hinter ihr
ist es zu sehen
ein wichtiger ort dieses capitol wohl
auch dieses mal wieder eine
amtseinführung stattfindet aber unter
ganz anderen vorzeichen nach 24 jahren
es ist wirklich ganz ganz anders als das
jemals zuvor in der geschichte war ich
stehe du sagst es richtig ganz in der
nähe des kapitols könnte viel hinter mir
sehen und ich stehe wirklich fast so nah
dran wie ich auch nur kommen konnte also
es gibt noch einen kleinen kleines stück
danach darf presse dann auch noch hin
aber was wirklich ganz anders ist
normalerweise werden hier um mich herum
ihr könnt es sehen
da ist jetzt leer und normalerweise
werden hier ja wirklich tausende
hunderttausende von menschen wir
erinnern uns an die bilder die wir
gesehen haben von amtseinführung zuvor
das ist dieses jahr nicht so aus
sicherheitsbedenken und natürlich wegen
der korona pandemie sind hier wirklich
gar keine zuschauer öffentlich
zugelassen und auch nur 1000 geladene
gäste also wirklich eine ganz ganz
andere amtseinführung als das jemals
zuvor der fall war
wie ist denn normalerweise die stimmung
da in washington wenn da jetzt
amtseinführung ist also ich erinnere
mich da an bildern von erfasst volksfest
ähnlich ähnlicher stimmung so was kennen
wir ja auch nicht wenn wir neue
bundeskanzlerin der bundeskanzler
kriegen machen wir keine party
das ist hier normalerweise eine riesen
party also wirklich eine party wo sie
hier ihre demokratie feiern und vor
allem natürlich auch den neuen
präsidenten und das war jetzt schon für
viele in diesem land also auch
enttäuschend ich habe eben gerade ein
paar vereinzelte menschen getroffen die
schon so nah hier an gebildet sind wie
sie nur konnten aber irgendwann ist
jetzt hier wirklich nämlich dann schluss
hier gibt es viele zäune und
absperrungen und da stehen dann die
soldaten der national guard und lassen
auch niemanden durch die menschen die
ich getroffen habe die heute hier
trotzdem runtergekommen sind an die
national mall oder in die nähe davon
muss man ja eher sagen die sind schon
enttäuscht die sagen mensch wie gerne
würde ich da jetzt stehen und würde wie
immer die der parade zu sehen und
mitfeiern und das geht eben nicht aber
sie versuchen also jetzt trotzdem so ein
bisschen völlig stimmung und das ist
nicht viel stimmung auf zusagen aber die
allermeisten sitzen von fernseher weil
dazu hatte selbst auch joe biden
aufgerufen
bleiben sie zu hause schauen sie sich
die feierlichkeiten auf dem sofa an
das ist also eine amtseinführung in
zeiten von corona stehen max noch einen
ganz kleinen schritt nach links gehen
weil wenn wir dich in dieser anderen
einstellungen haben dann wirst du immer
halb aus dem bild das ist schade müssen
kurz dazu sagen alis dann macht das
jeder als one woman show die hat kein
kamerateam dabei deswegen müssen wir das
nochmal so jetzt einrichten
wir haben das schon gesehen also die
ehemaligen präsidenten sind auf dem weg
wir hatten gerade im bild bei dir die
clintons die sich auf den weg gemacht
haben gleich kommen glaube ich auch noch
die bushs also george double you und
seine frau laura bush sollen kommen das
heißt die sind alle dabei aber einer
fehlt genau präsident trump
noch-präsident trump nicht mehr lange
nur noch eine stunde zehn minuten
der ist schon gar nicht mehr in
washington also der hat sie heute morgen
die stadt verlassen richtung florida in
sein privates ressort und das ist
wirklich auch wieder ein ein novum also
das gab es fast noch nie zuvor zumindest
nicht in der modernen geschichte dass
ein präsident also wirklich nicht bei
der amtseinführung des neuen präsidenten
dabei ist er hat sich dazu entschieden
es ist jetzt durchgesickert dass er wohl
zumindest eine notiz auf dem
schreibtisch von beiden hinterlassen
haben soll was darin steht und ob das
wirklich so ist das haben wir jetzt noch
nicht konkret bestätigt zu diesem moment
das waren also medienberichte aber es
ist richtig er wird nicht teilnehmen
vizepräsident pence hingegen der soll
also teilnehmen aber das ist wirklich
sehr sehr ungewöhnlich dass sie also ein
vorgänger dem neuen diesen diesen
übergang verweigert die bushs angekommen
sind da die treppen runter gelaufen du
hast gerade schon die hohen
sicherheitsanforderungen angesprochen
also das sieht ja hinter dir sie mal
ganz klein also wenn man hier gucken auf
dem bildschirm da sind soldaten also das
ist tatsächlich hoch gesichert viel mehr
als sonst wie erlebst du das denn ist es
da jetzt überhaupt möglich normal zu
arbeiten
die stadt gleicht wirklich einer festung
und das schon seit tagen und das fühlt
sich jetzt schon als jemand der hier
lebt auch ein bisschen komisch an jetzt
schon seit mehreren tagen zumal auch
hier in der stadt wir uns ein bisschen
natürlich auch fragen was an diesen
sicherheitsvorkehrungen was davon bleibt
mit sicherheit nicht die 25.000 soldaten
und dieses weite abgesperrte hier aber
es wurde schon angekündigt hier von der
bürgermeisterin würde ich jetzt mal
sagen hier dass street district of
columbia dass viele
sicherheitsvorkehrungen auch im
nachhinein bleiben sollen dass wir also
in eine zeit des der neuen normalität
eintreten denn es gibt da schon auch
befürchtungen dass jetzt auch in der
zukunft also ist ja vielleicht immer mal
wieder auch zu ausschreitungen oder
protesten bilden protesten kommen könnte
also manche sicherheitsvorkehrungen
werden bleiben und jetzt gerade ist es
wirklich das gespenstisch teilweise dass
die brücken hier richtung washington dc
zu gemacht worden der tunnel unter dem
kapitel ist geschlossen
ich habe gerade relativ lange gebraucht
um hier an diese position zu kommen um
mit euch zu sprechen das ist eher mühsam
sich derzeit fortzubewegen und um hier
rein zu kommen wurde ich also auch durch
einen metalldetektor test geschleust und
wurde da auch ganz genau durchsucht
wirklich jede tasche meinem eines
rucksacks ein großer spaß das weiß jeder
der sich mal mit amerikanischen
sicherheitsbehörden beschäftigt hat da
du uns gerade jetzt auf der position ist
so viel zeigen kann haben wir ein paar
bilder zusammen geschnitten das hat jan
friedrich fischer für uns getan
die amtseinführung von joe biden als 46
us-präsident sie wird anders als je
zuvor
denn schon seit tagen gleicht washington
einer festung nach dem sturm auf das
kapitol wurden die
sicherheitsvorkehrungen extrem
verschärft es herrscht angst vor neuer
gewalt von jump anhängern bei der
offiziellen zeremonie bleibt wenig
normalität auch wegen corona sind die
menschen aufgefordert zu hause zu
bleiben
200.000 fahren dienen daher als ersatz
für die zuschauermassen die
normalerweise auf dem parkstreifen vor
dem kapitol jubeln rund um die
regierungsgebäude gibt es einen zwei
meter hohen metallzaun und eine
weitläufige sicherheitszone 25.000
nationalgardisten sind im einsatz
auf den tribünen auf der westseite
dürfen aus sicherheitsgründen gerade
einmal 1000 gäste sitzen ja also
wirklich ein ziemlich ab gesichertes
prozedere heute und darüber spreche ich
jetzt mit kathrin klimas burg
politikwissenschaftlerin an der harvard
kennedy school in cambridge
massachusetts
guten morgen muss ich ja sagen bei ihnen
ist es ja gerade morgens bei uns ist es
nicht
wie nehmen sie wenn die stimmung jetzt
im land war die stimmung im land ist
jetzt erstmal gespannt aber freudig
gespannt der als einführungstag ist für
die demokratie amerikas in der regel und
es ist ein kernstück nochmal der
demokratie der friedliche die friedliche
amtsübergabe ist immer ein wirklich
interessanter tag ein jubeltag für viele
im land und das erleben wir natürlich
auch trotz dieser wenigen menschen um
das kapitol herum aber es wird eine
andere dynamik in washington sein es ist
eine andere dynamik
ich war bei der amtseinführung von
barack obama dabei dem bild sehen 2009
und das war ein großes volksfest wir
standen dicht auf dicht und trotzdem
haben wir uns so sicher gefühlt und so
ja fast geborgen in dieser
amerikanischen gemeinschaft das ist
jetzt natürlich jetzt ganz anders die
stimmung im land ist anders die
sicherheitslage ist wegen der erstürmung
des habe ich es am 16 januar ganz anders
es ist ein anderer neu anfangen aber es
ist doch ein neuanfang
ja wird ja auch doch jetzt gleich in
dieser zeremonie die wir nicht mehr
erleben dürfen sie wird ungefähr eine
gute stunde dauern
doch sehr sichtbar netter ist ja ein
sehr diverses publik also nicht publikum
sind diverse künstler sehr diverse
menschen eingeladen
was ist das ist das schon die botschaft
dass beiden sagt also das ist jetzt das
ende des komplett weißen amerika bei mir
wird es jetzt bunt vielfältig und auch
weiblicher ich glaube das ist ein ganz
wichtiges signal und glaube es ist auch
ein außenpolitisches signal
wir haben uns in europa vier jahre lang
ab kämpfen müssen mit dieser mit japan
gedachten bildsprache im amerika aus
einer bildsprache der die wir fast nicht
mehr gewohnt waren wir haben alle sehr
wohl verstanden dass amerika sich
demografisch und soziologisch
umschichtet dass bis 2050 aus diesem
land ein minderheit mehrheits landwirt
das heißt eben kein weißes land mehr
wird und dass und so die natürlich die
kulturkämpfe die jetzt vier jahre lang
sich quasi offen in amerika ausgetragen
haben
aber mit der zusammenstellung der sänger
der der poeten der vielen auftretenden
heute aber auch mit den signalwirkungen
dass die erste frau indianische afro
amerikanischen ursprungs von der ersten
latino bundesrichterin eingeschworen
wird sagt der beiden aus dass auch ist
amerika nein noch viel mehr
das ist amerika im herzen und er wird
uns seiner rede noch einmal darüber
sprechen dass es ihnen darum geht die
seele amerikas wieder hervorzuheben die
seele amerikas zu eigen macht und schon
für sich natürlich immer in anspruch
genommen hier gibt es eine frage von
einer zuschauerschaft von tim auf
youtube trump wird sich doch nicht ohne
großen knall verabschieden oder etwa
doch zwei fragezeichen er hat eine
abschiedsrede gehalten und die hat auch
jan friedrich fischer für uns mal kurz
zusammengefasst
nach vier jahren ist es vorbei donald
trump 8 ein letztes mal im weißen haus
auf und will nur eines sofort weg denn
entgegen der tradition nimmt er nicht an
der amtseinführung seines nachfolgers
teil hinterlässt ihm aber immerhin wohl
einen brief inhalt unbekannt
es ist eine große ehre die größte ehre
meines lebens die großartigsten menschen
der welt das großartigste zuhause der
welt wir hatten tolle vier jahre
wir haben viel erreicht kurz zuvor hatte
er in einer seiner letzten
amtshandlungen mehr als 140 personen
begnadigt darunter seinen ehemaligen
chef strategen steve bahnen wie es mit
ihm weitergeht bleibt unklar
am flughafen gibt er sich noch einmal
angriffslustig vor dem start nach
florida sagte er
habt ein gutes leben wir werden uns
wiedersehen
[Applaus]
ja das klingt fast ein bisschen wie
schwarzenegger in terminator i'll be
back
ist das jetzt der große knall also so
richtig knallig klangs nicht aber doch
nach einer ankündigung
ja er hat den satz fertiggemacht in
noranda und also auf einem weg oder auf
einem anderen weg und ich höre viele
deuten das als anspielung natürlich auch
seine familienmitglieder er hat auch
noch mal seinen familienmitgliedern
ausdrücklich gedankt
da kriegt man ziemliches magengrimmen
wenn man demokratie so versteht wie wir
es nicht tun nämlich dass volksvertreter
gewählt sein müssen und dass ihn auch
auf die finger geschaut werden können
muss den der buddhismus den wir im
weißen haus gesehen haben nämlich das
natürlich senior familienmitglieder der
tramp jean reno berater warnen dass auch
wenn sich die söhne quasi theoretisch in
das business verabschiedet haben sie
natürlich sehr wohl sehr viel wahlkampf
gemacht haben nun auch die demagogischen
botschaften dieses präsidenten immer
wieder ins land getragen haben nicht
zuletzt auch natürlich beim
republikanischen parteitag das ist so
die kampf angekündigt des donald trumps
das auf irgendeine art und weise in
anführungszeichen diese trump
islamistische bewegung weiter gehen wird
und er wird so lange er es kann
solange der ja die die enge des
zivilrechtlichen und kriminal
kriminellen prozesses die ihn die ihm in
new york und anderweitig in den usa
gemacht werden wird solange diese noch
nicht greifen wird er versuchen seine
bewegung am leben zu halten und sich
weiterhin ins gespräch zu bringen das
war zumindest die ankündigung bevor er
da in den flieger stieg bevor wir dann
noch mal vielleicht ein bisschen tiefer
ins gespräch gehen habe ich eine frage
aus der zuschauerschaft von mm 990 auf
youtube die sich jetzt um diese ganze
frage dreht was machen wir hier
eigentlich gerade warum machen wird
diese frage die ich eine stelle weshalb
deutschland sich so sehr betroffen fühlt
und so nach riesige frosch oder hat
interessieren sich die amerikaner dafür
wenn hier der kanzler gewählt wird oder
die kanzlerin wie können sie das
erklären also
es stimmt ja schon wir gucken in
deutschland immer sehr besonders in die
vereinigten staaten wie erklären sie
dass er das ergibt sich natürlich auf
der ganz besonderen geschichte nicht nur
also der gesamtdeutschen geschichte wo
die amerikaner wirklich federführend
dafür waren dass wir eine
wiedervereinigung hinbekommen haben
gegen die sich zb das vereinigte
königreich und frankreich unsere partner
in der europäischen union doch lange
gesträubt haben sondern eben auch die
gründung der abgabe des west
deutschlands nach dem zweiten weltkrieg
zurück wir verbinden
hass genetische angefangen lehre
verbindung mit den usa ohne den marshall
plan wäre deutschland nie so
wirtschaftlich erfolgreich gewesen ohne
die aufnahme 1955 in die nato wäre
deutschland nie geschützt gewesen um
gerade diesen wirtschaftlichen wachstum
auszubauen werden wir natürlich jetzt
genießen und wir denken an die vielen
amerikanischen truppen die jahre lang
und immer noch in unserem land
stationiert sind die sich natürlich
nicht was hat donald trump ja immer
falsch verstanden eigentlich um die
sicherheit deutschlands kümmern sondern
um die sicherheit der nato um die
sicherheit europas und die sicherheit
des transatlantischen bündnisses
diese aus diesen beziehungen und den
vielen schüleraustauschen und den vielen
hinter personellen kontakten über den
atlantik ohne diese transatlantische
freundschaft würde es mein eigenes leben
überhaupt gar nicht geben meine mutter
ist amerikanerin mein vater ist
deutscher ich bin amerikanische
militärkrankenhaus in der mitte hessen
sind der landeshauptstadt geboren
alle diese dinge verbinden uns doch auf
eine andere art und weise mit amerika
als zb ist andere länder tun und
deswegen haben wir natürlich auch diese
letzten vier jahre glaube ich als land
auch als persönlichen affront erlebt und
natürlich die persönlichen attacken des
präsidenten trump auf unsere
bundeskanzlerin auf bundeskanzlerin
angela merkel
die haben wir eben auch als persönlich
bedeutet umgekehrt glaube ich schon sehr
wohl dass zur bundestagswahl im
september
gerade diese beiden regierung und
natürlich auch die nun im nationalen
sicherheitsapparat eingesetzten figuren
sehr wohl auch die bundestagswahl und
auch europa schauen werden das sind
europäer durch und durch oder europäer
europäisch denken
durch und durch also machen sie sich
keine sorgen europa wird für diese
regierung eine große rolle spielen
sollte hier im stream wir haben noch
fünf minuten dann soll es richtig
losgehen
die sagen hier der länder gute präsident
geht also es gibt tatsächlich auch leute
die trump befürworten auch in
deutschland das ist vielleicht eine
minderheit aber es gibt sie und man
stellt sich ja doch manchmal die frage
hat denn der mann überhaupt nichts gutes
hin gekriegt
also das ist ja oft das urteil aus
deutschland auch aus den deutschen
medien reine katastrophe alles nur
schlechter gemacht alles nur schlimmer
gemacht finden sie irgendetwas an donald
trump an seiner politik wo man sagt okay
das hat einigermaßen funktioniert oder
was ist jetzt vielleicht tatsächlich
besser als es vorher war
es ist anders aber ist es deutlicher zum
beispiel hat eine sehr klare linie
gezogen gegenüber china auch gerade in
den letzten stunden hat der
außenminister michael paye noch mal
gesagt das war es hingegen über den
figuren gemacht hat das gleich in einer
konzentrat einem konzentrationslager
oder konzentrationslagern das sind tiefe
humanitäre vergeben das stimmt einfach
ist es natürlich eingebettet in einer
etwas schizophren und politik gewesen
die ja eigentlich immer nur auf die
ziele von donald trump gezielt hat aber
eine klare kante zu beziehen gegenüber
china ich hätte ihm geraten das so zu
machen wie er es macht aber das ist nur
in denen gängige einstellung in den usa
sowohl von demokraten wie auch von
republikaner das von china und dann
gleich gefolgt von russland als
autoritären staaten die größte bedrohung
für amerikaner amerikas wirtschaft und
amerikas politik ausgeht aber eben auch
für die demokratien an sich also da hat
er glaube ich amerika ganz klar
positioniert und diese dieser klare
trennlinie ist auch aus den köpfen aller
amerikaner wenn man so möchte jetzt
nicht mehr weg zu denken dass wir die
politik eines präsident beiden sehr
beeinflussen eine ganz andere politik
als die von barack obama und vielleicht
soll man ihm zugute halten er hat keinen
wirklichen neuen militärischen konflikt
angefangen selbst wenn er doch doch
äußerst militärisch aktiv war defekt
dessen nicht dass er die in
anführungszeichen mutter aller bomben
hatte abwerfen lassen und durch den
abzug verschieben verschiedene sicher
amerikaner
wir drucken gerade aus syrien in
bestimmten jahr wirklich volatilen
regionen der welt die situation sicher
noch unsicherer gemacht hat also für
mich bleibt unterm strich nicht viel
gutes ein gardetanz politik können jetzt
sehen wenn wir mal kurz die bilder
zeigen aus washington
dort kommt jetzt pünktlich nach plan den
ich hier auch habe der vizepräsident der
noch vize präsident mike pence mit
seiner frau angeht jetzt durch die
reihen wird sich gleich hinsetzen in der
ersten reihe und das ist ja auch schon
ein bild das er gekommen ist und donald
trump nicht was würden sie denn sagen
frau klieversberg was sagt das über die
republikanische partei aus dass donald
trump jetzt nicht kommen wollte aber
mike fenstern sich doch dorthin begibt
und der amtseinführung beiwohnt das
zeigt einfach ruhe wie gespalten die
partei ist zwischen den kern tram pisten
und der wollen wir sagen eher
traditionellen republikanischen partei
die auch diesen wahlsieg des toba
der ist einfach mal haushoch nicht
abzustreiten ist und dass das dazugehört
zu einem normalen demokratischen prozess
aber auch seinem ganzen
selbstverständnis hätte donald trump
dieser amtseinführung nicht beiwohnen
können und ich glaube für joe biden
werde es auch sehr schwierig gewesen
ein quasi einen antidemokratischen
demagogen man nehme sich nochmal gerede
vom 06
januar vor auf dieser tribüne sitzen zu
haben in dem moment wo es wirklich um
den fortgang das weiterbestehen und der
wehrhaftigkeit der amerikanischen
demokratie geht
ich glaube insgesamt ist das jetzt eine
ganz gute lösung und damit rechnen eine
kurze antwort weil das wird gleich
losgehen
dass er unterstützung bekommt vielleicht
aus reihen von republikaner nicht von
der ganzen partei die hat er weiterhin
ich denke an senat senator holly die hat
er weiterhin also die pisten im senat
sind weiter da und wie sie jetzt mit
diesem mit diesen macht spielt hier
innerhalb des senats umgehen das werden
die nächsten tage und wochen zeigen
hat er vielleicht tatsächlich auch
irgendwie verbündete innerhalb dieser
musikalischen partei die wissen dass sie
im grunde das ding an die wand gefahren
haben
ich glaube im inneren ihres herzens
wissen sie dass sehr wohl aber für sie
geht es darum bei der nächsten wahl
weiter im senat zu sitzen das heißt da
werden teilweise sehr gefährliche spielt
den betrieben nach innsbruck vielen dank
für ihre einschätzungen und für diese
vorbereitung auf das was jetzt kommen
wird es werden würde wieder spannende
vier jahre aber jetzt gucken wir erstmal
mit spannung nach washington
ich wünsche ihnen noch einen schönen
nachmittag und schönen tag so und wir
schauen dann mal nach washington und zu
meiner kollegin alicia die wenige
hundert meter von den bildern entfernt
steht die jetzt zu uns kommen
wir erwarten in wenigen augenblicken
dass der gewählte präsident joe biden
quasi auf dieses podium kommt wir sehen
in den bildern die ich jetzt hier links
die das könnt ihr nicht den alle warten
auf ihn
genau da sehen wir es besser wenn du mal
drauf guckt was da gleich filmprogramm
kommt sind das was was sind das für pro
forma die dann nachher auftreten werden
die sich die beiden administrationen
ausgesucht hat es beginnt zunächst mit
einem gebet von einem freund der familie
von pater leo trainerin der also ein
gebet zum anfang sprechen wird
anschließend das ist ganz traditionell
gibt es den sogenannten pleasure willi
gäns also den treueschwur der nation und
der fahne der flagge und anschließend
geht es noch weiter dass lady gaga also
die kennt ja wahrscheinlich wohl jeder
also ein superstar die nationalbank war
auch in den letzten jahren jahrzehnten
zuvor so also wirklich immer da meistens
ein großer star der die nationalhymne
singt beiden entschied sich also für
lady gaga und anschließend legen dann
die beiden das ist ja der der große
moment also kamera harris und joe biden
ihre amtszeit ab und dann im prinzip ist
es auch schon 12 uhr und das war er wird
die magische zahl ab dann sind also die
beiden im amt und eingeschworen ab dann
gilt es
und dann gibt es auch natürlich noch die
die antrittsrede von joe biden die wird
mit spannung erwartet also welche themen
witterda adressieren bochum wird es da
gehen da wird es also auch noch mal sehr
spannend vermutlich können wir uns
natürlich darauf einstellen auch die
korona pandemie wird hier also
aus dem raum einnehmen und
wahrscheinlich die bekämpfung der und
dann und das ist vielleicht auch noch
mal ein sehr spannender schöner punkt
wird es im anschluss daran ein gedicht
geben dass vorgelesen wird von einer
dichterin die erst 22 jahre alt ist eine
afroamerikanerin immenser gorman sie
kommt aus kalifornien und vielleicht was
auch noch besonders ist an dem man an
dieser jungen dichterin mit nur 22
jahren
sie litt selbst auch als kind an einem
sprachfehler und ich weiß nicht ob das
für das deutsche publikum auch so
bekannt ist auch joe biden hat
gestottert als kind lange jahre und hat
also das stottern überwunden und das ist
für viele menschen hier wirklich auch
ein großes zeichen die selber vielleicht
an sowas leiden oder gelitten haben dass
man also sowas auch überwinden kann und
dann auch tatsächlich so mutig auf
großen bühnen stehen kann wie jetzt im
länder kommen mit nur 22 jahren heute
die dichterin oder eben auch der
ehemalige stotterer joe biden der heute
dann auch eine rede vor einem millionen
milliarden publikum halten wird sagen
ist das ein cast der der sich heute
trifft und performance wird mit dem sich
auch hardcore republikaner anfreunden
können
naja das ist es ging schon jetzt einfach
darum bei der grundsätzlich bei der
ganzen gestaltung des tages das ist
schon um die einheit auch gehen soll und
auch darum republikanerinnen und
republikaner mitzunehmen also ganz
bewusst hat joe biden heute morgen auch
zum gottesdienst wichtige führende
republikaner eingeladen mit ihm dahin zu
gehen dass das galt schon allein auch
als ein zeichen natürlich dass er das
betont ihr ja immer wieder er möchte der
präsident für alle amerikanerinnen und
amerikaner sein das wird schwer das ist
ganz klar
vier jahre donald trump er hat viele
viele fans viele anhängerinnen und
anhänger nach wie vor das wird also eine
riesengroße aufgabe mit einer der
größten verlierer stehen wird und
deswegen ja es wurde auch bei dem
programm jetzt natürlich darüber
nachgedacht wie kann man auch einfach
alle mitnehmen und das ist ich habe
zuvor schon gesagt das was beiden selbst
auch immer wieder betont er möchte der
präsident für alle sein also es geht ihm
auch ganz klar darum eben
republikanerinnen und republikaner
anzusprechen wählerinnen und wähler klar
aus dem kapitol gerade neben dir wo
kamalla harris mit ihrem mann die
treppenstufen herunter geht um an der
zeremonie teilzunehmen
dieses kapitel ist vor ja gerade mal
zwei wochen von einer wilden horde
gestürmt wurden dann gibt es jetzt auch
fragen bei uns gibt es irgendwo unruhen
weißt du irgendwas hast du irgendwas
gehört ob es irgendwo knallt tatsächlich
gerade da lisa selbst unterwegs ja vor
nicht allzu langer zeit also von einer
dreiviertelstunde war ich selbst noch
auf der straße unterwegs von der stunde
und war an den zwei orten also die hier
in der stadt dafür genannt worden sind
die überhaupt möglich gewesen wären dass
da ein protest stattfindet in der nähe
der national mall und diese proteste
wurden abgesagt weil da also von den
veranstaltern gar nicht die gm titel die
genehmigung vorlag und aber auch eben
wieder hier sicherheitsbedenken und
corona das heißt also an den
ausgemachten stellen kommt es gar nicht
zum protest ob es vielleicht an anderen
orten in der stadt dazu kommt das ist
natürlich jetzt gerade zu diesem
zeitpunkt nicht abzusehen aber auf gar
keinen fall das kann man glaube ich er
guten gewissens sagen hier in der nähe
des kapitols weil das ist einfach mit so
einem sicherheitsaufgebot geschützt da
wird es wirklich jedem sehr sehr schwer
gemacht hier durchzukommen das geht
wirklich nur mit einem bestimmten
ausweis und dann auch wirklich nur
einer einer kontrolle und deswegen das
ist also nicht so einfach hier irgendwie
nah an die ja nie szenerie ranzukommen
wir gerade von einigen kommentatoren
auch kritisiert da heißt es dann ich
möchte noch kurz gucken
das sieht so ein bisschen aus wie bei
der kommunistischen parteien china
demokratische freiheit geht anders oder
25.000 soldaten und polizisten wo ist
denn das in nordkorea kannst du das wird
nochmal kurz erklären warum wir jetzt so
viel militär und auch
sicherheitsvorkehrungen sind also auch
in den jahren zuvor das
sicherheitsaufgebot in der stadt
hochgefahren wird wenn hier eine
amtseinführung eines präsidenten
stattfindet das ist ja auch ganz klar
hier sind jetzt hinter mir auf der bühne
beim kapital also die wichtigsten
politikerinnen und politiker die jetzt
hier diese die situation zurzeit hat und
die sind ja alle in einem raum oder auf
einem ort er sie sind ja nicht in einem
rahmen sondern stehen auf einer
plattform und natürlich wird das
besonders geschützt das ist auch in
normalen jahren so jetzt kommt hier
natürlich hinzu wir hatten uns ja schon
auch kurz angesprochen dass es hier also
diesen sturm auf das kapitol gab also
diesen aufstand hier in der stadt und
das kapitol ja auch tatsächlich gestürmt
wurde also der menschen eingedrungen
sind und dann hat man natürlich noch
einmal die sicherheitsvorkehrungen hier
enorm hochgefahren weil auch und das war
in den letzten wochen haben dass also
die sicherheitskräfte des fbi auch
beobachtet ist immer wieder in online
plattformen auch die rede davon war dass
also hier proteste zumindest geplant
waren und einfach weil man das gelesen
hat wollte man hier vorbereitet sein und
hat dann dementsprechend also wirklich
hier mit einem hoch aufgebot an soldaten
die jetzt die sicherheitskräfte
zusammengezogen weil man das natürlich
auf jeden fall verhindern wollte und
natürlich auch hier die sicherheit all
dieser prominenten politikerinnen und
politiker und insbesondere natürlich des
neuen präsidenten garantieren muss so
jetzt haben wir schauen wir mal kurz
rüber hier ist gerade vizepräsident oder
die noch nicht vereinigte aber bald
künftige vize präsidentin kamera harris
mit
man eingetroffen sie begrüßen
unterschiedliche andere gäste und das
ist ja doch auch ein zeitenwechsel das
wird die erste frau und dann auch noch
die erste afroamerikanische frau auf
diesem amt sein und es wird tatsächlich
damit eine neue zeit anfangen alisa oder
damit wird auf jeden fall natürlich eine
neue zeit anfangen das ist ein
historischer moment also das gab es
vorher noch nie noch dazu wird auch das
beiden kabinett also sehr divers sein da
werden nicht nur sehr viele frauen
vertreten sein
ist es glaube ich sogar recht genau die
hälfte hälfte männer hälfte frauen das
ist also auch gibt es so auch nicht
nicht allzu häufig und noch dazu sind
hierbei auch tatsächlich sehr divers
also da gibt es einfach auch menschen
unterschiedlichster herkunft da gibt es
leute die einen lateinamerikanischen im
background haben oder auch noch andere
schwarze menschen eine indigene
ministerin die innenministerin und da
wird also auch ein sehr diverses
kabinett zusammengestellt das sind sowie
beiden es nennt sein eigenes kabinett
also ein kabinett der ersten male weil
es eher einfach zum ersten mal an so
vielen stellen also jemanden installiert
hat der jetzt vielleicht nicht sagen wir
mal ein weißer mann das problem also
warum haben die vereinigten staaten so
lange gebraucht um tatsächlich dahin zu
kommen dass auch in der regierung und in
den offiziellen ämtern sichtbar wir das
dieses land eben nicht nur aus weißen
männern besteht
naja man muss fairerweise dazusagen also
oft bill clinton hatte schon wirklich
ein diverse das kabinett und auch obama
hatte an diverse das kabinett unter
trump ist jetzt tatsächlich wieder nicht
so aber das ist vielleicht auch
natürlich ein bisschen den unterschieden
der beiden parteien geschuldet also
republikanerin republikaner mehr im
versus demokraten also es gab es schon
auch zuvor in der geschichte deswegen ja
es ist vielleicht jetzt in diesem jahr
man kann das jetzt vielleicht auch
einfach nicht mehr leugnen dass dieses
land ein diverses land ist und möchte
das auch gerne abbilden das ist auch gut
und richtig so aber ist es nicht so als
hätte ist es nicht auch schon in der
vergangenheit gegeben
wie gesagt clinton und obama hatten auch
schon recht diverse regierung richtige
recht diverses kabinett geht nach wie
vor ein älterer mann
als präsident jetzt meinst du ja es ist
der älteste präsident das ist ganz
wichtig da gab es natürlich im vorfeld
auch schon bedenken deswegen war ja dann
auch der die wahl seiner vizepräsidentin
für viele menschen so wichtig weil sie
eben gerne wissen wollten was ist denn
wenn vielleicht beiden jetzt nicht vier
jahre lang durchhält präsident zu sein
wer steht denn da in zweiter reihe
deswegen war das hier eine große
diskussion und für viele menschen ganz
besonders wichtig wenn er zu seiner vize
präsidentin gekürt ich gesagt habe sogar
die erste afroamerikanische frau das
klingt ein bisschen rassistisch ist es
klingt nicht rassistisches nicht
rassistisch gemeint ist einfach nur
tatsächlich ein anerkennen dessen was
fakt ist nämlich dass sie die erste
afroamerikanische frau in diesem amt ist
gast ist jetzt einfach noch nicht der
fall gewesen ist und so jetzt wird es
langsam da sehen wir die ersten bilder
von joe biden vielleicht können wir kurz
rüber schalten liebe regie joe biden ist
im capitol und betritt jetzt gleich das
podium ist auf dem weg und dann wird es
richtig losgehen sie sind eigentlich
wenn ich mal in den ablauf kommen
einigermaßen in der zeit das heißt
gleich wird's spannend gleich beginnt
das offizielle programm und ich bin
natürlich auch sehr gespannt die lady
gaga die nationalhymne performen wird
und interessant ist auch das glaube ich
dieser priester der mit den beiden
befreundet ist ist ja nicht irgendwer
alice hat er hat sogar habe ich gelesen
hat in deutschland studiert und es wird
er ist ein katholischer priester das
heißt wir haben jetzt auch tatsächlich
vier mal nach langer zeit einen menschen
mit katholischen bockhorn welche rolle
spielt das eigentlich in den usa was
täglichen background jemand hat er das
spielt hier eine sehr große rolle
tatsächlich und das war auch ich meine
mich eingelesen zu haben zu erinnern
also wirklich zu zeiten von präsident
kennedy auch noch noch ein thema hier
tatsächlich ob jetzt hier jemand
katholisch ist oder eben nicht
katholisch sondern eine andere einer
anderen religionsgemeinschaft angehört
tatsächlich ist darüber jetzt 2020 das
jetzt also beiden katholisch ist weniger
ein thema darüber wurde nicht so viel
gesprochen ist wurde aber tatsächlich
bemerkt dass
vielleicht jetzt auch weniger ein thema
ist das ist also tatsächlich für ihn und
auch für so viele andere menschen in
diesem land keine rolle spielt welchen
glauben du hast du das glauben was du
möchtest und an wen du möchtest und er
ist aber ein mann des glaubens das ist
tatsächlich glaube ich für viele hier
sehr wichtig glauben in diesem land
spielt für viele menschen eine rolle
und deswegen dass er einen ein mann des
glaubens ist das war fehlen dann doch
sehr wichtig da ja auch auf die bibel
schwören ist das eigentlich irgendwo in
der konstitution vorgegeben dass er auf
diese stören wird muss oder würde auch
ein koran oder eben was anderes gehen da
erwischt du mich jetzt gerade bei einer
frage dann würde ich jetzt lieber nicht
drauf antworten wollen wann ich mir
nicht hundertprozentig sicher bin was
ich allerdings weiß ist dass das wohl
seine familienbibel ist also auf die ihr
schon wirklich sehr sehr viele eide
geschworen hat das ist ja nicht zum
ersten mal dass ein eher ein politisches
antrag also diese bibel ist ihm auch
tatsächlich sehr wichtig ist es eine
eine bibel aus seiner familie aber mit
dem anderen fakt da wäre es toll wenn
die community man nachschauen könnte
dass wir da ganz sicher sein kann sind
zeit und kannst du nicht alles wissen
das sind ja schon selbst die details die
man für den heutigen tag wissen muss und
sohn jetzt sehen wir hier wieder die
fanfaren das wird sehr viel militärmusik
gespielt am heutigen tag mit vielen
verfahren ich glaube jetzt können wir
über schalten auf die bilder denn gleich
wird joe biden das podium betreten
[Applaus]
[Musik]
grußworte
[Applaus]
[Musik]
also das ist hat sich auch jetzt die
ersten worte hier gerade an die zeiten
des krieges als das hat die polen und
nicht richtig braucht um weiter gebaut
werden sollte
kritik daran und dann wurde gesagt nicht
organisch vizepräsident jetzt aber sagt
den schultern von so vielen dieser
plattform und sie hat den weg nach vorne
geschafft
und wenn sie das ein trend werden kleine
kinder auf der ganzen welt wissen dass
alles möglich ist und zum schluss ist
das ja amerika kunst wird demokratie ein
land von so viel gutem und heute auf
diesen stufen des kapitols widmen wir
uns wieder
[Applaus]
und jetzt ist es eine ehre vorzustellen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wissen sollen dass ein senator
kambodscha hier spricht dann ist es
etwas schneien
heute morgen aber von allen dingen die
ich gedacht habe war schließlich nicht
dabei aber dank es natürlicher und dank
auch an die mitglieder des gemeinsamen
kongress komitee für die amtseinführung
wir beginnen mit 459 zeremonie und ich
möchte hier noch mal unsere gedanken wie
sie mit diesen gesamten umständen
umgegangen sind vor vier jahren
da habe ich die beschreibung diesen ort
beschrieben hat das 89 und wunderlich
gerade weil wir das alle vier jahre seit
1789 gemacht haben die amerikaner haben
diesen moment gefeiert im krieg in der
depression und jetzt auch während einer
prämie noch mal alle 32 unserer
regierung kommt zusammen so wie das die
verfassung vorsieht
und wir erneuern unsere verpflichtung zu
unserer demokratie und einer dass die
menschen
der grund dafür sind dass dieses land
existiert
nach dem ersten dreier warten kam die
worte man sollte eine perfekte union
schaffen es ging nicht darum eine
perfekte union zu schaffen dass artikel
ohne väter nicht gesagt sie hat nicht
gesagt dass sie verbessert werden müsste
die gründerväter haben gewusst dass wir
immer das einarbeiten müssten noch
besser zu werden dass das das zeichen an
der großen demokratie wäre die
freiheiten die wir heute genießen die
nation die wir heute haben sind nicht
hier weil sie einfach so geschah und wir
sind auch noch nicht am ende eine große
demokratie lebt von den erfolgen und dem
versagen der geschichte und versucht
immer besser zu werden wissen mehr als
wir gewesen sind und für sie weniger als
wir hoffen zu sein
der angriff auf das kapitol hier zwei
wochen erinnert uns daran dass eine
regierung die sich selbst auszeichnen
will sich selber kontrollieren will
unsere frei und hat zu großen opfern
geführt und ist immer noch eine
herausforderung dieser herausforderungen
zu gehen war eine große aufgabe für
wissenschaftler für für erste war
überall und vielen anderen von denen wir
abhängen in so viele beweise
heute kommen wir zusammen und menschen
auf der ganzen welt beobachten uns dass
wir hier tun unsere regierung zusammen
berichtet die regierungsverantwortung
eine politische partei ist heute
glücklich als eine andere das ist immer
so aber dies ist nicht ein moment der
spaltung sondern ein moment der
vereinigung eine neue regierung beginnt
und bringt mit sich einen neuen anfang
und damit
und eine entschlossene demokratie wird
weiterhin wichtig seien um eine perfekte
union eine bessere zukunft für alle
amerikaner herzustellen was für ein
privileg dass ich heute hier bei uns
sein darf vielen dank
[Applaus]
und jetzt rufe ich einen freund auf die
rohdaten wird ein gerät sprechen
bitte verstehen sie auch für die
nationalhymne und für das gelöbnis
in dieser heiligen zeit kommen wir zu
dir was bekommst du die brauchen dich
wir sind auf unseren ziehen aber wir
kommen auch mit hoffnung und unsere
augen schauen die vision einer
perfekteren union in unserem land eine
union aller und soja um den allgemeinen
wohlstand zu erhalten und um den segen
der freiheit für uns und unsere
nachkommen zu erhalten
hier sind menschen viele rassen
glaubensrichtungen farben nationaler
hintergründe und vieler lebensziele und
wir sind jetzt viele menschen mehr als
wenn erzbischof sein gebet schrieb für
die amtseinführung von george washington
vor 232 jahren ich hoffe bei uns bist
und dem präsidenten der vereinigten
staaten unterstützt so dass seine
regierung rechtschaffen ihr amt ausübt
und nützlich sein wird für sein volk wir
unsere vergangenen sünden zu wenn ich
genug getan haben für die inklusion und
den freiheit aller aber wir erneuern
unsere vision und um uns zu kümmern in
worten und taten insbesondere um die
ärmsten unter uns um so ein dicht für
die ganze welt zu sein
es gibt eine kraft in jedem von uns lebt
dadurch dass wir uns einander zuwenden
mit dem geist anderen beizustehen und
gerade auf denen die dies am meisten
benötigen und das nennt man liebe und
wir nennen das heute amerikanischen
patriotismus
hier geht es nicht um macht oder
privileg sondern darum dass wir uns um
das gemeinwohl kümmern
mit bösen absichten gegen niemanden und
guten absichten ging war allen wir
bitten für unseren präsidenten um die
weisheit
wir bitten um eigentlich verstehen das
herz so dass er das volk regieren kann
mit dem unterschied zwischen recht und
unrecht kennt und wer an gott glaubt
wird diese weisheit finde daran erinnert
wie wichtig es ist zu träumen
gemeinsames zu träumen
er schrieb wenn wir nur und selber sehen
sehen wir dinge die nicht da sind
träume werden gemeinsam aufgebaut der
liebe gemeinsam uns unter unserem neuen
präsidenten die menschen in unserem
lande zusammenzuführen
wir haben unser tor gesehen wir wollen
dass gerechtigkeit
dazu kommt und dass die liebe über
fließt in deinem namen für immer armen
unter tel
[Musik]
die nationalhymne durch lady gaga
begleitet von der im bett
nein
[Musik]
si
bei
[Musik]
und so
bottrop
[Musik]
soja
links
[Musik]
doch
[Applaus]
für das die republik für die sie steht
eine nation unter gott freiheit und
gerechtigkeit für alle
[Applaus]
was heute sehen ist ein historischer
moment
die obersten gericht der vereinigten
staaten gegeben hat richter denn bitte
bleiben sie stehen
bitte geben sie ihre bestand und
wiederholen sie ich kann maler
detailwissen feierlich dass ich das amt
das ich die verfassung der vereinigten
staaten nach besten kräften erhalten und
fertigen fertig gegen alle feinde im
ausland im inland und dass ich als
gemäss folge dass ich die schlichtung
übernehme und jede wurde jedes zögern
ohne dass ich davon zurück gehen will
und dass ich werde ich mein amt aus 5
wehrte die pflichten des amtes dass ich
übernehme so wahr mir gott helfe
[Applaus]
[Musik]
bitte nehmen sie wieder platz
begleitet von der united states marine
band
[Applaus]
[Musik]
bis 9
ist man immer von kalifornien new york
[Musik]
ist
juli
ok
ach so ronny
ast bin
sein
[Musik]
mm
euro
[Musik]
disney
juli
[Musik]
nein
juli
[Musik]
da
gewinnt
[Musik]
rosumek
also das ist quasi jetzt der erste teil
gewesen dieser amtseinführung sehr viel
symbolik haben wir gesehen lady gaga mit
einer großen friedenstaube auf ihrem
gewehr
jennifer lopez ist gerade mit einem lied
des land ist mailand russland in der
version von verschiedenen amerikaner
songs wie es heißt und zwischendurch hat
sie sich an die lateinamerikanischen
menschen in den usa gewarnt
die spanisch sprechenden und jetzt jetzt
richtig ernst ist die anzahl führung der
amtszeit in diesem präsidenten nicht
starten
joseph biden sie stehen für den amtseid
bitte geben sie ihre rechte hand und
wiederholen sie sehr schwierig ich
feierlich dass ich das amt des
präsidenten vereinigten staaten
getreulich verwalten werde und nach
besten kräften die verfassung der
vereinigten staaten erhalten schützen
und verteidigen will
so wahr mir gott helfe obama gefällt
herzlichen glückwunsch herr präsident
[Musik]
[Applaus]
und damit ist es vollbracht joe biden
ist als 46 präsident der vereinigten
staaten eingeschworen wurden und wir
hören gerade im hintergrund die
präsidiale hymne hail to the chief
gespielt für ihn und jetzt warten wir
darauf dass gleich seine ersten worte
als amerikanischer präsident an das
amerikanische volk richten wird wir
sehen hier wie sie eine sehr begrenzte
zuschauerzahl es sind nur 1000 menschen
zugelassen aufgrund der kroner pandemie
normalerweise sind es hunderttausende
die bei dieser zeremonie dabei sind
heute geht's halt nicht unter großen
sicherheitsvorkehrungen
alles starrt eben wegen der vorfälle vor
zwei wochen als das kapitel gestürmt
wurde
und jetzt sind wir gespannt was die
beiden als präsident in seiner rede an
das amerikanische volk handelt
dies ist ein moment auf den wir alle
gewartet haben
es ist jetzt meine große ehre und ein
privileg die erste person zu sein
die offiziell 46 präsident der
vereinigten staaten
[Applaus]
oberster richter
naja man kann die beste mitbürger dies
ist amerika star
das ist der tag der demokratie alltag
der geschichte und der hoffnung der
erneuerung der entschlossenheit ein
schmelztiegel für die zeiten amerikas
wieder getestet worden und ist der
herausforderung gerecht geworden heute
feiern wir den triumph nicht eines
kandidaten sondern einer sache der sache
der demokratie die menschen der wille
der menschen ist gehört worden und der
dem willen des volkes ist gefolgt worden
und wir haben wieder gelernt dass die
demokratie wertvoll ist und fragil und
in dieser stunde hat die demokratie
obsiegt meine freunde nun auf diesem
heiligen boden hat vor kurzer zeit erst
die gewalt versucht die grundlagen
dieses kapitals zu erschüttern aber wir
sind zurückgekommen dass eine nation
unter gott untrennbar um einen
friedlichen übergang der macht
durchzuführen wie wir das schon während
der jahrhunderte gemacht haben und ich
schaue nach vorn los
mutig um die nation zu sein die wir
immer waren und sein müssen ich danke
meinen vorgängern
aus beiden parteien dass sie es nicht
angehen aus der tiefe meines herzens
dafür und ich weiß dass unsere
verfassung widerstandsfähig ist und dass
sie stark ist ich weiß dass unsere
nation stark ist und das weiß auch
präsent karte mit dem ich letzten abend
gesprochen habe kann ich hier sein und
wir würdigen ihn für sein lebenswerk und
für seinen dienst
[Applaus]
ich habe einen heiligen eid abgegeben
den auch alle anderen zur apathie roten
abgegeben haben der zuerst von george
washington abgegeben wurde
aber die amerikanische geschichte hängt
nicht von einem 101 oder einigen von uns
ab sondern hängt ab von uns allen
wir das volk die wir eine perfektere
union wollen
das ist eine großartige nation wissen
gute menschen und während der
jahrhunderte in stürmen und in
schwierigkeiten und streit in frieden
und dem krieg sind wir so weit gekommen
aber wir haben immer noch weit voran zu
schreiten wir werden nach vorne gehen
mit großen drang denn wir haben sehr
viel zu tun in diesem winter der risiken
und der großen möglichkeiten ist es viel
vorzubereiten wiederherzustellen und zu
heilen und vieles ist zu gewinnen
wenige menschen in unserer geschichte
haben größere herausforderungen bestehen
müssen da haben vor schwierigeren zeiten
gestanden als wir heute das ist ein
virus den es nur einmal im jahrhundert
gibt der unser land durchzieht und in
einem jahr so viele menschen getötet hat
wie amerika im zweiten weltkrieg
verloren hat millionen von
arbeitsplätzen sind verloren gegangen
unter tausende unternehmen müssen
schließen
für gerechtigkeit das bringt uns der
traum für trächtigkeit für alle wird
nicht weiter aufgeschoben
[Applaus]
der kampf um das überleben ist daneben
steht für uns und das ist ein buch der
nicht verzweifelter sein könnte und wir
hören ihnen jetzt
wir müssen über den extremismus weiße
überlegenheit und rechts radikalität um
diese herausforderungen zu überwinden um
die seele und die zukunft amerikas
wiederherzustellen
dafür brauchen wir mehr als worte wir
brauchen demokratie das ist einheit
einheit ein weiterer januar
63 die emanzipation seite heiter stehen
und trinken sagte damals dass mein name
in die geschichte ein gestimmt sein wird
dann durch dieses gesetz meine seele
steckt darin meine ganze seele steckt
darin
und heute heute an diesem januartag da
steckt meine ganze seele hier in amerika
wieder zusammenzubringen unser volk zu
vereinen unsere nation zu vereinen
und ich bitte jeden amerikaner mit mir
zusammen an dieser sache zu arbeiten
[Applaus]
gemeinsam können wir gegen unsere gegner
kämpfen so gut hass extremismus
gesetzlosigkeit gewalt krankheit aber
süßigkeit hoffnungslosigkeit können wir
mit einheit besiegen können wir große
dinge erreichen wir können
ungerechtigkeiten rückgängig machen
wir können unsere kinder erziehen
schulen retten und wir können gemeinsam
diesen tödlichen virus übung kommen
wir können amerika sicher für alle
machen will können passen gerechtigkeit
herstellen und wir können amerika wieder
zu einer führenden kraft des guten in
der welt machen
ich weiß wenn man über einheit heute
spricht dann klingt das man wie eine
verrückte idee denn die spaltung ist
tief und real aber ich weiß auch dass
dies nichts neues ist unsere geschichte
war ein ständiger kampf zwischen dem
amerikanischen ideal dass derartig
gleich geschaffen sind und der harten
hässlichen realität des rassismus das
nati wyss muss der angst der
dämonisierung und diese kräfte haben uns
lange gespalten
der sieg ist niemals sicher der
bürgerkrieg die große depression
september aber trotz allem haben die
listen engel immer obsiegt um diesen
momenten gab es genug von uns die
zusammenkamen um uns alle nach vorne zu
bringen das können wir jetzt auch wieder
tun
die geschichte der glaube die vernunft
zeigen uns den link den weg der einheit
wir können uns nicht als gegner sondern
als nachbarn de können uns tag behandeln
mit würde und respekt und unsere kräfte
zusammen in degen
hören wir auf uns an zu schreien
reduzieren wie die temperatur ohne
einheit gibt es keinen frieden nur
bitterkeit und wo kein fortschritt nur
erschöpfung und wut keine nation nur ein
status des chaos das ist unser
historischer moment eine krise ist eine
herausforderung und die einheit ist der
weg nach vorn und wir müssen
diesen moment als die vereinigten
staaten von amerika dann gehen wenn wir
das tun garantiere ich dass wir nicht
versagen werden
wir haben niemals in der geschichte in
amerika versagt wenn wir etwas zusammen
angepackt haben und heute zu dieser zeit
an diesem ort
fangen wir einfach neu an die alle
fangen wir an uns zuzuhören und zu hören
uns zu sehen
respekt zu zeigen gegenüber den anderen
die politik muss nicht ein rasendes
feuer sein dass alles in seinem wege
zerstört jede unterschiedlichkeit der
meinungen muss nicht zu einem totalen
krieg führen und wir müssen die kultur
eine kultur zurückweisen wo die fakten
manipuliert und erfunden werden
[Applaus]
amerikanische mitbürger wir müssten
etwas anderes stadt amerikas besser als
das americas viel besser ist das schauen
sie sich darum
hier stehen wir im schatten dass der
kuppel des kapitols und diese kuppel
wurde mitten im bürgerkrieg vollendet
als die union an das messer schneide hin
hier stehen wir
wir blicken hinaus auf diese große wo dr
von seinem traum sprache stehen wir bei
108 jahren bei einer anderen
amtseinführung tausende von protestieren
versuchten tapfere frau die einen marsch
für das ist wahrlich durchführte
amt gebracht und ihren amtseid gehört
kamera harris hier stehen wir nicht weit
entfernt vom linken friedhof wo unsere
helden ihr letztes opfer gebracht haben
und den ewigen frieden ruhen jetzt
stehen wir hier tage nachdem ein
aufständischer pöbel versucht hat den
willen des volkes umzukehren und
versucht hat uns verlassen weg zu jagen
das passiert nicht das wenn die passiert
nicht heute nicht morgen niemals niemals
wird das passieren und ich bin dankbar
dass sie uns vertraut haben während
unserer wache part i und ii uns nicht
gewählt haben dient sage ich messen sie
mich und mein herz und wenn sie immer
noch nicht einverstanden sind mit ihr
gut das ist die demokratie das ist
amerika das recht friedlich eine andere
meinung zu haben
das ist vielleicht die größte stärke
dieser nation
hören sie mich ganz deutlich
unterschiedliche meinungen müssen nicht
so uneinigkeit führen und ich verspreche
ihnen ich werde ein präsident aller
amerikaner seien alle amerikaner und ich
verspreche ihnen ich werde genau sein
hat für die kämpfen die mich nicht
unterstützt haben als ich für die kämpfe
die mich unterstützt haben vor vielen
jahrhunderten gesagt
die menschen sind eine gruppe von
das ist das gemeinsame unserer liebe in
amerika ich glaube wissen dass das ist
die möglichkeit etwas zu schaffen
sicherheit freiheit würde respekt wäre
und die wahrheit ja die letzten wochen
monate haben uns eine stimme lektion
gelernt
es gibt weit in den lügen lügen die für
macht und profit genutzt werden jeder
hier als amerikanischer bürger als
amerikanisch besondere als führer hat
eine verantwortung wir haben versprochen
unsere verfassung zu ehren unsere nation
zu schützen und die wahrheit zu
verteidigen und über die lügen zu
obsiegen
ich verstehe dass viele meiner mitbürger
die zukunft mit angst und unruhe sehen
sie am angst um ihre arbeitsplätze
ich verstehe dass sie nachts an die
decke stecken entdecken kann ich mir die
krankenversicherung leisten kann ich die
hypothek bezahlen kann ich meine familie
ernähren und was kommt danach
ich verspreche ihnen ich verstehe das
aber es hilft uns nicht wenn wir in
konkurrenz der fraktion und zurück
zurückziehen oder wenn ich mir den traum
die an einem von gott glauben oder
anders aussehen wir müssen diesen und
bürgerlichen krieg enden
rot gegen blau steht wo die mannschaft
im lande gehen die menschen in städten
stehen
wir können es schaffen wenn wir unsere
seelen öffnen statt unsere herzen zu
verhärten
wenn wir ein bisschen toleranz zeigt und
ein bisschen demut
und wenn wir willens sind uns mal in die
rolle der anderen zu versetzen wie meine
mutter immer sagte nur einen moment
versetzt sich die rolle der anderen
denn eines ist sicher im leben
man weiß nie was einen das schicksal
bringt
an manchen tagen von einer helfen
brocken ein helfer hand und dann gibt es
andere tage da möchte jemand unsere hand
halten
darum geht es das tun wir für einander
und wenn wir so reagieren damit unser
land stärker wohlhabender bereiter für
die zukunft auch wenn weber noch anderer
meinung sind meine amerikanischen
mitbürger in der zukunft brauchen wir
uns alle wir brauchen unser aller
stärker um durch diesen dunklen winter
hindurch zu kommen und das ist
möglicherweise die schwierigste zeit
dieses virus und wir müssen gemeinsam
als eine nation dieser pandemie angehen
als eine nation und ich verspreche ihnen
dieses wie die bibel sagt wir würden
etwas in der nacht tun egal wie
schwierig aber am borg ob das nicht wir
werden das zusammen durchstehen zusammen
schauen sie all die kollegen mit denen
ich im senat zusammengearbeitet habe die
alle verstehen dass die welt uns
zuschaut
sie schaut uns allen heute und hier ist
meine botschaft für die jenseits unserer
grenzen
amerika ist getestet worden und wir sind
aus dieser prüfung
wir werden unsere bündnisse reparieren
und wieder mit der welt zusammenarbeiten
nicht um gestern die um die
herausforderung von gestern zu
überkommen sondern um die
herausforderungen von heute und morgen
zu überwinden und nicht nur durch das
zum beispiel unserer macht zu führen
seien durch die macht unseres beispiels
zu führen
wir werden ein starker vertrauensvoller
partner für frieden und sicherheit sein
sie alle wissen dass wir so viel
durchlebt haben in dieser nation und in
meiner ersten handlung als präsident war
ich sie bitten mit mir zusammen zu
stehen in einem moment des gebetes für
all diejenigen die wir in diesem jahr an
die pandemie verloren haben diese
400.000 amerikanischen mitbürger mütter
väter eheleute kinderfreunde mitarbeiter
während sie in dem wir die menschen und
die nation werden die wir sein können
und werden
und ich bitte um ein gebet für
diejenigen die ihr leben verloren haben
und die für unser land gestorben sind
amen
liebe mitbürger dies ist an der zeit der
prüfung
wir haben einen angriff auf die
demokratie und die wahrheit und einen
virus wir haben systemischen und
rassismen wir haben eine klimakrise
amerikas rolle in der welt diese punkte
sind herausforderungen große
herausforderung für uns aber die
tatsache ist wir blicken diesen
herausforderungen leicht entgegen und es
ist an der größten verantwortung und das
nation die wir gehabt haben wir werden
jetzt geprüft werden wir aufstehen und
mutig handeln ist es zeit für mut denn
so viel muss getan werden
und eines ist sicher ich verspreche
ihnen wir werden gerichtet sie und ich
daran wie wir mit diesen kaskadieren den
krisen zurecht kommen werden wir die in
dieser seltene stunde meistern werden
die der verpflichtung gericht und können
wir unseren kindern eine bessere welt
hinterlassen
ich glaube wir werden das schaffen und
wenn wir das tun
kapitel in der geschichte der
vereinigten staaten von amerika die
amerikanische geschichte die geschichte
die zeigt wie ein lied klingt das ziel
für mich bedeutet das ist die
amerikanische hände und da gibt es einen
vers der besonders ist für mich
zumindest und da heißt es die arbeit und
die gebete von jahrhunderten an diesem
tag geführt aber es wird unser erbe sein
was wäre unsere kinder sagen lass mich
wissen immer am herzen wird meine tage
vorbei sind amerika amerika ich gab mein
bestes für dich lassen sie uns
hinzufügen unsere eigenen worte unsere
gebete für die sich entfaltende
geschichte unserer nation wenn wir das
tun
wenn dann unsere tage gezählt sind dann
werden unsere kinder und enkelkinder von
uns sagen sie gaben ihr bestes
sie folgten ihrer pflicht sie halten ein
gespaltenes land liebe mitbürger ich
bitte den tag dort wo ich begann mit dem
heiligen eid vor amerika und ihnen allen
habe ich ihnen mein wort gegeben dass
sich immer für sie das entwertet dass
sich die verfassung verteidigen werde
unsere demokratie verteidigen werde und
amerika verteidigen werte und ich werde
ihnen alles geben ich werde ihnen dienen
es geht nicht um das persönliche
interesse skaten das öffentliche wohl
und zusammen schreibt wir eine
amerikanische geschichte darf und nicht
angst einheit nicht trennung nicht
dunkelheit eine geschichte der des
anstands und der würde der liebe und der
heilung der großartigkeit und güte das
sollte geschichte sein die uns führt und
inspiriert eine geschichte die den
nachfolgenden generationen sagen wird
dass wir auf den ruf der geschichte
geantwortet haben dass wir für
demokratie hoffnung wahrheit und
gerechtigkeit gekämpft haben und dass
amerika zu hause feiert erzielt hat und
stolz darauf geblickt hat das ist das
was wir den vorgängern schulden und den
nachfolgenden mit voller absicht und
entschlossenheit wenn wir uns den
aufgaben unserer zeit zu unterstützt
durch den glauben
angetrieben durch die überzeugung für
die mitbürger nord amerika segnen und
möge nordamerikas truppen segnen
danke
[Applaus]
das war also die erste rede von joe
biden als neuer präsident der
vereinigten staaten es war was was ich
sagen würde eine präsidiale rede fast
schon eine predigt ich fast noch mal
ganz kurz zusammen er hat sich als
präsident aller amerikaner bezeichnet
hat sehr auf zusammenhalt hat den
zusammenhalt sehr betont der meinte
verschiedene meinungen müssen nicht
streit bedeuten die demokratie habe sich
durchgesetzt er hat gesprochen über den
angriff auf das kapitol vor zwei wochen
er hat von lügen und von hetze
gesprochen er will sich gegen rassismus
und inländischen terrorismus einsetzen
dass alles deute ich als klare
kampfansage an das erbe von donald trump
er möchte den krieg beenden wo rot gegen
blau stehen hat er gesagt also die
demokraten und die republikaner die
anhänger beider parteien die sich den
letzten vier jahren sehr unversöhnlich
gegenübergestanden haben möchte die
herzen öffnen demut zeigen und hat die
menschen dazu aufgerufen sich in die
rolle der anderen zu versetzen ich
schalte jetzt noch mal zu meiner
kollegin an dieser jungen die wenige
hundert meter von ja diesen ort des
geschehens steht das alles mitverfolgt
hat also auf mich wirkt das tatsächlich
fast wie eine predigt wie hast du das
wahrgenommen
es waren jedem fall eine sehr präsidiale
rede und ich würde sagen wirklich so das
hauptthema seiner rede ist ganz klar
gewesen er möchte der präsident sein der
dieses land wieder ein er hat es
angesprochen hat es auch gesagt also die
spaltung in diesem land ist tief und sie
ist real
das hat er anerkannt und das hat er auch
tatsächlich als eine seiner größten
herausforderung oder vielleicht sogar
als die größte anerkannt also da weiß
joe biden dass er da wirklich eine große
große aufgabe vor sich hat er weiß wie
viele menschen in diesem land
tatsächlich ja auch große fans auch noch
nach wie vor von von donald trump sind
und dass er es sehr schwer haben wird
bei den zu punkten und deswegen hat er
ganz besonders insbesondere versucht
diese menschen also anzusprechen hat
immer wieder also davon gesprochen und
das einheit die lösung ist dass sie es
mit einheit in diesem land weit bringen
können dass sie damit die probleme hier
überwinden können und das war wirklich
so seine seiner haupt
seine hauptbotschaft seine haupt message
er möchte das sagt er schon seit wochen
er möchte der präsident für alle sein
und hat also ganz klar dass als seine
größte herausforderung formuliert und
auch noch dazu hat er natürlich schon
auch angesprochen er weiß wie fragil wie
zerbrechlich die konstitution also sein
kann und hat also da auch gesagt er
möchte also für die demokratie kämpfen
für die demokratie einstehen
weil auch da gab es in den letzten
wochen ja durchaus befürchtungen dass
das die hier so ein bisschen auch ja
zumindest angekratzt wurde in diesem
land aber das ist ja schon wieder fast
schwierig oder wenn auf der einen seite
jump anhänger stehen die das gefühl
haben die wahl ihres präsidenten ist
geklaut worden
also die demokratie ist schon kaputt er
sagt demokratie hat sich durchgesetzt
das sind ja zwei lesarten oder zwei
völlig verschiedene realitäts
wahrnehmungen der letzten wochen die
sich eigentlich doch gar nicht
miteinander verbinden lassen oder
deswegen wird es auf jeden fall
natürlich für ihn er wird ganz ganz
schwer haben er wird jetzt natürlich
auch er bekommt jetzt hier ein ein land
überlassen
dem ist natürlich sehr sehr schlecht
geht durch die korona pandemien
wirtschaft geht es nicht gut vielen
menschen ganz persönlich geht's nicht
gut viele menschen sind bereits
gestorben sehr sehr viele sind erkrankt
und deswegen er bekommt ihr natürlich
auch ein erbe das es ihnen nicht leicht
macht und gleichzeitig aber auch eben
ein wirklich zerrissenes und tief
gespaltenes land das hat er also
anerkannt das ist wirklich sein alles
erklärt das ziel das er also dieses land
wieder ein möchte und er sprach eben
auch davon dass er weiß einfach es geht
ohne einheit gibt es keinen frieden und
kein fortschritt und erforderte quasi
ein bisschen in neustadt erforderte vor
allem auch mehr respekt mehr verständnis
füreinander also einander die hand
reichen
davon hat er gesprochen wie wichtig das
also ist ich habe hier immer wieder mit
menschen natürlich auch tagtäglich zu
tun und auch besprochen und so habe ich
aber so auch in den letzten wochen mit
trump fans gesprochen also auch nach dem
sturm auf das kapital und also bei
einigen war dann doch am ende des tages
auch immer wieder der satz na ja gut
wenn es denn dann ist also beiden jetzt
wenn er dann präsident ist dann würden
sie es akzeptieren das sind bestimmt
nicht alle da gibt es also auch noch
eine gruppe wie gesagt bei der wirt
beiden ist
schwer haben und vielleicht werden sie
ihn auch nie wirklich lieben akzeptieren
aber er möchte zumindest alles dafür tun
so sagt er dass er also der präsident
hier für alle sein kann
wer den entscheidenden moment verpasst
hat in dem joe biden den amtseid
geleistet hat für den haben wir denn
jetzt gerade nochmal vorliegen und wir
gucken uns diese entscheidenden sekunden
noch mal zusammen du kannst du zwischen
und die inhalte in stades kasse tischen
und ihnen zuhörte komiker
[Applaus]
[Musik]
also viele hoffnungen ruhen auf diesen
präsidenten wenn ich einmal hier in
unseren städten gucke dann gibt es immer
wieder kommentatoren kommentatorinnen
die sagen ja jetzt ist er weg jump hat
zumindest keine neuen kriege geführt
wann fallen die usa wieder in ein neues
land ein also dort die befürchtung dass
sich die außenpolitik ändern wird wie
schätzt du dass einen die ist beiden da
auch unter präsident obama auch getreten
also ja natürlich gibt es also eine
historie in diesem langen langen leben
von joe biden der ja eben auch schon an
der obama regierung beteiligt war
wo jetzt einfach viele sagen wird er in
sachen beispielsweise außenpolitik wird
er also da jetzt irgendwie eine politik
fortführen wie wie man sie bereits schon
von ihm kannte wie er sich aber dazu
also zumindest in der letzten zeit eher
positioniert hat war ich glaube was
jetzt ganz stark im fokus steht also
jetzt vor allem auch in der ganz nahen
zukunft ist erstmal hier wirklich die
die politik im land es geht um amerika
in dem falle amerika auch wieder auf die
füße zu kriegen also die ersten 100 tage
der beiden präsidentschaft werden
wahrscheinlich auch in sachen corona
pandemie im ganz im zeichen der korona
panini stehen in der bekämpfung also es
gibt genug im land zu tun
es ist tatsächlich wenig im gesamten
wahlkampf von der außenpolitik die rede
gewesen das war auch für die wählerinnen
und wähler wenig entscheidend
tatsächlich denn es gibt so viele
probleme hier vor der eigenen haustür
dass es tatsächlich die innenpolitik
sein wird die kind der kampf gegen
korona und das wieder auf die füße
kriegen der amerikanischen wirtschaft
was hier ganz klar und ganz eindeutig im
fokus steht weil das ist das was was
hier die menschen im land beschäftigt
und wo auch jetzt wirklich als
allererstes sehr sehr viel zu tun ist
also viel zu tun für den neuen 46
präsidenten der vereinigten staaten joe
biden der jetzt vor wenigen minuten
vereidigt wurde alisa vielen dank dafür
dass du uns das all das erklärt und
eingeordnet hast ich sage bei euch
vielen dank fürs zu sehen für eure
kommentare und fragen und sagen für
heute machen wir den screen zu dass zum
nächsten mal macht gut
[Musik]